Calvin Johnson's going to be on Dancing
with the Stars so that immediately led
us to say is he a Hall of Famer if I
said yes or no right now Calvin Johnson
how would you answer yes ok uh who
stabbed yes we can't be we can't be
slaves to numbers you must respect
somebody's numbers but you can't be
slaves to numbers you have to look at
how a guy played versus other receivers
in his era and the respect he got from
other from the corners from defensive
coordinators I just think I'm not saying
he's a singular receiver in his time but
he certainly is one of the great
receivers of a time when receivers are
at the peak uh impact in NFL history no
I know it's always a tough topic for you
because you're in that room and it gets
heated you guys are rarely complimented
on hey great job in the hall of fame
class here so yeah let's see what else
do I want to ask you if I it's more
interesting for you the Broncos
quarterbacking situation the Cowboys
quarterbacking situation or San
Francisco's quarterbacking situation
well San Francisco's quarterback
situation is interesting from an MSNBC
point of view when when I pull my
Twitter followers on Sunday night and in
a two hour period more than 9,000 more
than 9,000 respond I've never had more
than a thousand people in any poll I've
ever done but more than 9,000 respond
and they basically are fifty-fifty split
down the middle it's 5149 okay that you
know that on whether Colin Kaepernick
you know should have done what he did
and does he have the right to do what he
do 9630 votes it's incredible so so for
for for the front page of The Daily News
impact
a you know in our society today we're
we're so divided that one but in a
football I i mean i'll just say with
denver what impresses me so much is how
Gary Kubiak handled this he never handed
this job to mark sanchez he said let the
best man win he opened the competition
for four months and the best man won
consistently Trevor simeon was better
now that's not to say he's going to do a
great job but I like when a coach says
the best man will play and then he
doesn't gerrymander the rules as he goes
along I think he did a really good job
as far as Dallas goes then I just look
at Dallas and say that I've never forget
being with the Cowboys on draft weekend
and watching Stephen Jones for 67
minutes and at least 19 phone calls with
nine teams that period of time that
effort trying to get Paxton Lynch and
Stephen Jones told me sunday afternoon
we would not right now trade dak
Prescott for Paxton Lynch straight up
now he's going to say that you know he's
going to say that but in Dallas camp
where I was for a day and a half this
this is a there's a love affair with dak
Prescott going on are we overreacting to
dak Prescott of course but that's what
happens in the ring and you know what
are you going to do but you know you
don't you don't want to you don't when
you look around at the NFL okay and when
you look around and see the exit
presence has done nothing this pretty
thing because you've been hurt Jared
Goff has been shaky for the Rams even
though you could look at and say well
Jared Goff played against the ones a lot
more than sendak Prescott did you know
so you look at this and you basically
say you know everybody relax take your
time just let the guy play and we'll see
if he's any good but you have to be
encouraged watching him be an eighty
percent pass over the hundred
thirty-eight rating in three games you
Peter King the mmqb calm joining a Stan
Patrick show you got one question to
colin kaepernick what do you ask you
seem like you are willing right now to
sacrifice your career for this story why
now why are you doing it right now um
and look I think a lot of people dan
will say that hey where's this been all
the time with Colin Kaepernick I think
that's really really unfair people
evolve they change their mind and I'm
not going to compare this situation
directly to that but you know for 25
years I call them the Washington
Redskins and I just think that the name
is wrong right now I don't think you
should you know use a name that even
though the washington post poll said
that the vast majority of Native
Americans don't mind the name I think
there's enough who do that I would not
walk up to somebody and say hello
[ __ ] so I have a respect for that and
that's why I'm not going to use the name
anymore and I think Colin Kaepernick got
to the point that he basically said I
can't sit quietly anymore and watch this
so I applaud him but whether he's
willing to I'm not saying sacrifice his
career but whether he's willing for his
career to take a hit because of this
that's what I'd want to explore with him
a couple other topics Joey Bosa is
finally in camp about what was solved
here in with both sides I'm not anything
at all the Chargers basically said look
the way we do Rookie contracts is that
we defer some of the bonus money till
the following year it doesn't seem to me
to be worth it to hold out to really
adversely affect your rookie year with
Joey Bosa was willing to do I mean why
would anybody really care whether you
and I'm gonna invent these numbers
because I don't know
what they are you know get 10 million or
12 million this year and then four
million in 2017 who on earth cares is
that worth holding out for a month it
wouldn't be to me I would be telling my
agent hey forget this I I want to be in
camp in the offset language i think is
really in my opinion it's a Trojan horse
that I don't think it's important but a
lot of agents and a lot of players think
it is I don't think anything was gained
at all and I don't think it'll mean
anything next year except that the agent
will prove that he's not uh that he's
that he's got enough guts to hold a guy
out of camp and again he's going to have
to determine whether that's going to
help him get players or not next year
more likely to miss the playoffs
Carolina or Denver I mean I guess you'd
say Denver because of the quarterback
situation and because of a very strong
division with the exception of San Diego
and on the other hand you know you'd
look at Carolina and say it's a weak
division and they got everybody back and
pretty much so I'd probably say Denver
but i still think Denver is going to
make the playoffs your super bowl pick
do you have it I don't have it yet I'm
mulling around four teams right now I've
decided in the NFC it's a team from the
Upper Midwest but I'd like to have a few
more days mullet around Dan if you don't
mind and Dan by the way yeah I know that
nobody has said this to you yeah but
welcome back from South there thank you
Peter thank you it's good to be back I
never thought that I would I I would
embrace our homeland quite like I did
when I landed I was I was very happy to
be back there did you have a good time
ah it's a lot of work it because people
think boy you're on the beach I'm not
I'm not on the beat i mean i'm working
on the beach boy all those great events
well i'm working while you're watching
those great events my family is like oh
yeah
really looks like tough work over there
dad and I go I'm working so i didn't get
to again you know what I if I can just
take 30 seconds you know was interesting
because I don't get to watch these
things I'm going from training camp to
camp and all that stuff Oh what was so
interesting is so many players loved the
Olympics they love Usain Bolt after the
the Chargers Cardinals preseason game a
couple of weeks ago were led into the
Chargers locker room after the game in
King Dunlap and four guys are all like
peering into his smartphone watching a
replay of the Usain Bolt gold medal
relay and they're just they're fired up
and everywhere I went Carson Palmer said
man I love the volleyball I mean you
know it was just Johnny hekker man
Simone biles best athlete I've ever seen
and things like that it was just it was
really really interesting to see the
hold that the Olympics had on NFL
players I've said to people if you
really want to be able to see an NFL
game being on the sidelines is gives you
a completely different perspective and
watching Usain Bolt run in person is
completely different than watching him
run on TV and then when I saw Tony Dungy
there I said Tony could you use him as a
wide receiver and he said I would just I
would just spread him out and let him go
and you know he said but all it takes is
one hit and then Usain Bolt will run
differently once one of those guys yeah
yo kam chancellor hits him Usain Bolt
all of a sudden is not the fastest man
in the world you know I had I had one
coach say to me we were just standing
around talking and he said what would be
what you would do is you would put a
strong safety in the five-yard bump zone
and you just try to abuse him because
obviously he's going to get behind any
corner yeah and and so that but it would
be really interesting I didn't hear any
general managers that I asked a few
Germany interest in signing Usain Bolt I
think that they would be so cautious and
so reticent simply because I don't think
he's played football you know and so it
would be difficult for him yeah well
plus you make so much money you know
when your make
25 30 million dollars in track there's
no reason you know Bob Hayes needed to
make money that's why when yeah that's a
very good very good point very good
point Pete thanks for joining us as
always we'll talk soon thank you all the
best damn take care Peter King the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience